[Música]
[Aplausos]
pues voy a comenzar con estos circular
porque es armar la ior
esta frase popular de nuestra cultura
gracias a esa primera persona se burlan
de mí nier en un backstage de un
concierto
y que bueno ahora se utiliza diferentes
por los para una de una forma retórica
preguntarse algo que en realidad no
estás plano que tenga respuesta yo lo
que hice en mi primer conexión que
presente la forma más importante de
mundiales
también es sumamente importante que una
licencia de lo que todos reconocemos
como
y vivir de una u otra forma en que
brando de esta y el resurgimiento y está
en las dos etapas de ella ahora con toda
la habilidad social
y de la facilidad que tenemos para
comunicarnos y de expresar algo y
entonces utilice esta claridad con el
afán de burlarme mucho de mí y de la
historia detrás de la línea que como
muchos saben de pronto en menos de dos
semanas el nombre les va a sonar gracias
a una verificaciones y llegada de
búsqueda de la moda sin una carrera
al menos reconocida y presentarme
coleccionando a la plataforma de arte
moral entonces ha sido utilice y les voy
a contar un poquito de mi historia
para poder llegar hasta los momentos no
por fáciles tengo más de 13 años en la
industria de procesamiento del
desarrollo textil para hacer moda no
para hacer artículos que hice con ellos
la historia fue complicada estudie en
las cuales que días antes
básicamente me entré a la universidad
justo antes de irme estudie en españa
evolución musical
siempre como relacionado con las artes
descubrir de muy chico que el diseño
pintar la arquitectura me llama mucho la
atención
y antes de ir estudiando literalmente
con discriminación encuentro con los
polis y niveles arts que básicamente era
como cumplía todos los requisitos para
poder una universidad y este era tener
un poquito de todas las carreras de
diseño todas las disciplinas de distinto
pueden llegar a existir porque al final
yo sabía que quería este moda siempre
estoy entre la música y la moda en las
dos caras que más me llama la atención y
bueno pues se volvió bien interesante a
nivel acotar las puertas con los que la
directora de gnc en cuanto a patricia en
que yo recuerdo con mucho cariño me
abrió la puerta a dos de retirarse con
la bolsa en el hombro y un suspiro
profundo y medios cinco minutos tiempo
explicarme que una escuela
multidisciplinaria la única escuela que
tenía un programa de estudios en el cual
puedes llevar la industrial y textil y
al final especializarte algunas veces
entonces básicamente desarrollo me
convenció de quedarme
el transcurso de la carga y muchísimas
cosas conocían en eso se lleve a salir
con quien fundó una compañía llamada
passión marketing solución a la historia
la compañía tampoco es fácil obviamente
iniciamos con un proyecto de la escuela
del cual queríamos hacer moda
y crear en confeccionar y desarrollar
mercados de distribución etcétera
etcétera y hoy conocimos para que le
guste la moda no está funcionando el
país como deberíamos como hoy en día
está empezando a funcionar y la realidad
es que esto pues gracias a dios ha
sucedido por la permeabilidad que
tengamos de las redes sociales hoy en
día por la tecnología ya no dependemos
de monopolios no dependemos de una
empresa que tenga un estudio es que sea
para darnos digamos que la promoción que
están buscando en ese momento
pues bien topé con este quebranto de la
industria de la moda del país el nombre
fashion week' había sido prohibido
utilizarse en el país no habían las las
formas de moda surgieron hay dos tres
elementos que es organizado pero todos
tienen un enfoque meramente social será
un lugar donde cada seis meses la crema
y nata de la sociedad y más que todo
alguna compra estaba de una pasarela se
retira mente se quedaba cuatro meses más
sin hacer nada de su vida al menos en
sus historias más cercanas
que yo tuve con las personas que con
nosotros y dos hijos contemporáneos de
de ellos
en esa época y pues es quebrantado y
triste después de la primera exposición
de pruebas donde no presentarnos
meramente una colección
de nuestras piezas dentro del marco
lleno
del evento
creo que este no es el camino creo que
si seguimos acá nunca vas a la industria
y en el país nunca vas a cambiar la
perspectiva y deberíamos buscar la forma
de hacerlo diferente que es lo que hace
falta bar un diseñador de modas
infraestructura un lugar de bastardear y
tus diseños de despacho es el personal
de la proveeduría en méxico para
diseñadores guerrerense es sumamente
complicado en realidad no existe
la mayoría de los proveedores están
tentados a producir en masa volumen y de
pronto acercarte como diseñador
independiente
a producir algo sobre todo con los
volúmenes que diseñadores reciente puede
manejar por la capacidad de lenga que
tiene y de expansión y en ese momento
muchísimo de puntos de distribución en
ese momento había 34 tiendas de moda la
ropa
estoy en una empresa que es enfocar a
desarrollar uniformes corporativos en
publicidad que aplauden durante los hace
hace dos años los últimos diez años de
mi vida eso es lo que estuviesen
desarrollen campañas para diferentes
marcas desde jerzy stuhr chains o car
por diante motorola excendencias de
alice desde la playa de árbol o para el
promotor de un evento de marketing o
oeste offline o lo que estudian sus
listas del cliente hasta desarrollo de
sastrería y el panal informes de
inauguración de pierre chance excederse
de venganza dos hermanos el pasamos por
por muchos por los besos en los padres
aprendimos a desarrollarnos templo de la
industria
principalmente con materiales nacionales
[Música]
los procesos son muy artesanales y
porque no sean marcas
y las de la marca
esta maquinaria tenía como un tipo de
comunicación nos gusta mucho trabajar a
la conclusión del tipo de marca que
tenía que ser y del tipo de público que
la tenía que experimentar y al final ese
es el es el resultado del trabajo para
dios que vivimos con el proceso y ya ver
más me ha ayudado muchísimo
hardware face off
no me gustaría son axtel resumiendo que
trabajan muchísimo para llegar a más
pero la realidad es que lo hemos hecho y
nos hemos comprometido con el músculo
sos comprometido con nuestros socios
comerciales nos hemos comprometido con
todas las cosas que nos enviaron de las
cosas que más nos representan muy fuerte
es que tenemos un nivel de compromiso
como si fueran para nosotros mismos nos
gusta atender al público nos gusta
tolera a nuestros clientes directamente
nos gusta estar pendientes de nuestro
negocio
y hemos vivido de todo tipo de pasos
para hacerlo desde un día hasta tarde
las costureras con todas las personas
que trabajan con nosotros etcétera
etcétera viajaría de madrugada para
entregar el pedido porque no estaba
llegando a tiempo y la verdad es que es
parte de la evolución conteniendo
y dice esto
después de estos 10 años trabajar con
con mi socia y de haber tenido pasión
arquette y solución a la paz
desarrollado wilde a mi prima vuelta
de la noche de manera decidimos
separarnos y la verdad es que siempre en
un poco de presión me di cuenta que no
era fácil después de haber tenido una
vida conjunto y haber crecido no he
experimentado miles de formas con con
una persona especialista en esto se
acabó
pero de lo que se estaba seguro y ya ves
que 2/3 pláticas con mis personas más
cercanas me ayudaron a confirmar es que
yo no quería encargando nada de lo que
habíamos hecho me quedaba con todo el
conocimiento que queda por toda la
evolución que hemos tenido y con todo lo
que yo podía hacer con eso que había
desarrollado el trabajo que había vivido
a lo largo de esos años
y esto sucedió en 2016
por allí del mes de agosto y para
septiembre
tienes más importantes
y con mayor relación
s
y le pedimos es que nos separa y empezar
de cero que te hacemos otra de las cosas
importantes del por qué está esta
conferencia se llama el sistema son que
este nombre lo desarrollamos unos días
después de haber conocido esta persona
que ahora es mi socio y que literalmente
me sacó de un bache creativo y mental de
italia porque yo decía sigo dedicándome
a esto
como diseñador si hay alguien aquí que
estudie el sueño después de presentar
una colección es como el top
cada vez que
[Música]
era el camino correcto para saber que la
moda no era solamente presentarse en la
pasarela que hay niños de negocios y
entonces que te pones en súper feliz yo
puedes hacer una días entre la música y
la moda era algo que me podía haber
vuelto loco y me cambió la vida
representa américa dorama tu compañía
que hoy junto con el ico dirijo y
y más en la parte creativa
pero con
principalmente
cambiar la perspectiva de lo que da la
vida teorías 92 conciertos y regresar a
las bandas independientes de lo que
estaban invirtiendo para darnos
felicidad por llamarlo de alguna forma
era un circuito en el cual se nombra más
la música el éxito compraba largarse
oficial seguía esperando informada que
es quieran preparando o produciendo
música ante lo que es escuchar no
entonces me parece un proyecto súper
bonito y como ya les dije en relación a
la música la moda de hacer una alianza
entre las dos es una de las cosas que
más ha marcado mi vida
hoy por hoy dentro del mercado la mente
seguimos haciendo espero tenerlo porque
se trabaja con clics internacionales y
colaborar con las bandas más importantes
del mundo quería yo y bueno a raíz de
eso
nuestro primer viaje a los ángeles para
tocar puertas con algunos clips a los
pies hemos distribuido el producto pero
que no hayas tenía un acercamiento
formal para costarles todas nuestras
capacidades de diseño y de producción
me encuentro porque en la pasión que
tenían todos estos clips por trabajar
con gente méxico era enorme y
regularmente estos estos tienes trabajo
con proveedores chinos y pues los que ha
trabajado con proveedores chinos sabrán
que la comunicación el cambio de horario
la distancia siempre son un problema
entonces más allá de sólo eso yo la
cercanía con méxico y del idioma y de
los tiempos para entregar productos
nos emocionaba mucho ver como siempre
había un mexicano involucrado en los
procesos creativos en el diseño en las
industrias que hoy -por de formar parte
de la cultura popular y que además forma
parte de nuestra vida que nos dedicamos
a hablar de la música y alice y deberes
muy inspirado alberto de toda la calle
dedicas con seriedad porque además
llevamos literalmente con dos pesos en
la bolsa nuestras maletas llenas de
muestras y muchas ilusiones en una en un
fin de semana que teníamos
aproximadamente dos juntas tal vez tres
puntas tenemos el mismo como 10 y
realizamos con proyectos asegurados
entre ellos vodafone y de regreso diseñó
esto que es lo que me puso donde estoy
yo quiere hacer un informe que nos
representan para todos los colaboradores
de mente adoran brillantes abran la
historia después tengo fotos disputas
contables pero en realidad debemos
involucrar a ilustradores gráficos
nacionales para poder quebrar dar un
poquito a la piratería y tima pudiera
tener el mismo producto que nosotros y
todos estos ilustradas nos representan a
nivel internacional es importante para
mí tener un uniforme que hablara de
méxico y que les hablar en un idioma en
el cual el mundo se entera de piedad que
se trata principios de es una frase
sumamente discutible y sabíamos que iba
a haber mucha gente enojada con esta
década porque en inglés no porque 17
porque en ese contexto porque tiene una
connotación negativa en cuanto a la
palabra no y la realidad es que después
no lo diseñamos con el afán de agradarle
al público nacional del uniforme interno
pero ya qué pasó tenemos muchos
proyectos para poder hablar bien de ella
para el mundo que somos innovadores
y hacemos las cosas bien que los
necesitamos nos unimos estamos unos con
otros
tenemos la capacidad de levantar un país
después de un terremoto de una manera
impresionante
teniendo en extremo gracias a méxico y
diet
hoy estamos gobernadora más yo como no
rayón y dónde está alrededor de nosotros
han tenido la oportunidad de acercarnos
al público y todo esto con el afán de
hacer crecer industrias pero edad a las
generaciones que vienen un poquito más
de facilidad para que podamos crecer y
para que podamos realmente tener
una industria a nivel internacional
posicionada y que nos represente el país
de una manera diferente
recientemente esta última colección
mercedes fashion week y quería
enseñárselo es porque al final esta
parte de trabajo y de comunicación son
prestados
en mi mente y en mi vida y esta es una
de las de las colecciones con más
trabajo que hemos tenido y donde además
involucramos a un chorro hay gente que
es creativa que ha desarrollado ahora
que es amante del exacto haciendo que se
suma a proyectos de este tipo y sabemos
una serie de visuales increíbles y
además que la oportunidad por primera
vez de colaborar con una marca
internacional
en haití donde desarrollen un chelsea
que además pero guys un chorro hablar de
por qué no solamente el esfuerzo de la
empresa es que se va a vender en ellos
porque es la primer colaboraciones en
méxico que se desarrolla en méxico sino
que se está conduciendo en el país
tienen importante para seguir impulsando
las crisis de las textiles entonces lo
bueno es esa parte de seguir trabajando
a seguir colaboraba seguir presentando
gente importante y por último va a ser
nada concluyente hoy me gustaría cerrar
estos platicándoles un poquito en mi
experiencia de lo que están
y cuesta aquí en mi socio me encantaría
darle las gracias personal
[Aplausos]
mejor es que nos haga crecer gracias por
este viejo perdón
[Aplausos]
[Música]